The global economy today friends is like a monster truck with the gas pedal stuck...
...and we have lost the key.
And the only way we're gonna catch that truck is with a disruptive breakthrough.
And the only way we're gonna get a disruptive breakthrough is with a completely different mix...
...of standards, regulations, incentive, and taxes...
...that will trigger that disruption,...
...which is why my fundamental rule is change your leaders, not your light bulbs.
Oh, it's great to change your light bulbs,...
...but if you don't change your leaders, if you don't change the leaders who write the rules,...
...who trigger the innovation, we are cooked.
So what I've been trying to do in the new book I'm writing...
..is basically, in my own little way is to try to reshape how we think about this problem...
...because we actually think we're having a revolution and we're actually having a party.
But one of the real problems in getting people to rethink this problem...
...is getting them to rethink the meaning of green.
One of the big problems around green is that, I'm a big believer to name something is to own it.
If you can name an issue, you can own an issue.
The world is flat.
And the problem with green all these years is it was named by its opponents.
Basically, they named it liberal, tree - hugging, sissy, girlie man,...
...unpatriotic, vaguely French, just vaguely French, something about it vaguely French okay?
Well, what I'm really out to do is to rename green.
We name it geo - political, geo - strategic, economic, capitalistic, entrepreneurial, patriotic.
Green is the new red, white, and blue. Thank you very much.